[Music]
we had heard for weeks that the deals
were coming they're finally here let's
start with the network that matters the
most to us
here on peacock and that is the national
football league will continue to be
televised on sunday nights
by nbc an 11 year extension plus
expansion of sunday night football
through
20 33 when i will be
extremely old instead of just kind of
old
nbc sports presents for the next 13
super bowls
kickoff game thanksgiving night wild
card divisional playoff
awesome great stuff oh and and
and by the way starting on monday
uh am i allowed to say that matt am i
allowed to say what's coming back on
monday
can i say it okay i'm gonna wait i don't
want to jinx it and uh anybody out there
who's been watching the show carefully
probably knows what i'm talking about
but miles
these deals all of them run through 2033
nbc sunday night football abc espn
monday night football afc package on cbs
nfc package on fox everything's the same
the only difference
amazon as of 2023 is going to slide in
to the thursday night football roles so
if you don't live in the markets where
those games are played because they'll
surely be televised there
on a local network over the air for free
you're going to need amazon prime to see
those thursday night games
except for some of them that will be on
nfl network as is currently the case
with the
the fox games on thursday night so not
much
change but one significant change in
thursday night
yeah that thursday night change i think
is pretty significant and i think that a
lot of people at this point are used to
going to amazon prime to watch things on
demand
but it's the one time that you're going
there for a live football game
that it's like oh i guess i'm doing this
thing now and
we did that in december where they had
that one saturday game
between the cardinals and the 49ers and
i thought that they did a good job with
the game presentation it was pretty easy
to find because they had it splashed
all over that front page there when you
logged into the thing on your television
so
i i think that look it's it's an
interesting opportunity because
at a certain point in a couple years
especially
probably more people are going to be
streaming things on a day-to-day basis
than are going to have cable right
so at least if you have that now built
into
this series of contracts the next series
of contracts is going to be really
interesting to see
where exactly streaming goes and it's
going to be interesting to see where
exactly streaming goes
with the sunday ticket package in the
next couple of years too
what do you have what do you use as a mo
as the as the resident millennial what
do you use for tv
i use all kinds of things i use directv
because i like
to have an actual thing but i'm not the
i'm not the typical person
because i know i know a lot of people
usually use youtube tv i have in the
past used uh the playstation view
rip to that uh streaming service because
it was great because it had
your nfl network your nba tv and all
those mlb network and i like watching
live sports right and it's kind of an
essential function
for what it is that i do because if i
couldn't see games mic i don't think you
would be very happy with me
uh so yeah i that's what i use but i
think that i'm not really
that typical of a millennial just
because of the way that my tv viewing
habits are
and that's a good point you need to have
access to the sunday ticket package when
you're covering the nfl
i don't because i get pumped into the
studio
when i'm here or otherwise i'm at nbc
and we get to see the sunday games there
so i have youtube tv because i'm telling
it's so much cheaper than directv and
it's so easy to use and it's on all your
devices and that's where the world's
moving and
by the time we get to the end of these
deals yeah
streaming may have taken over for
everything and that's why
the thing that fascinates me the most
about these new packages
there's an out for the nfl or one time
out nbc announced in its statement
seven years in there's an out i'm told
they're not
all lined up the same way the different
packages have different outs
but the nfl has the power to say we're
pulling the plug
and one of the reasons you put that
power in there is so you can do it
and my guess right now if i had to wager
it would be they're going to do it
because the way the world continues to
change
there will be more value especially as
gambling matures
when they get the technology the point
where you can do play-by-play in-game
betting
the world will be very different the
money will be larger
and the nfl will be able to say
we're willing to pull the plug here and
pivot either
you give us more than you were supposed
to give us to stay or
we're going to take this somewhere else
and by the time we get to whether it's 7
or 11 years from now
the digital companies will will be
bigger
they'll have more money they'll be more
powerful and
i you know that that may be where the
ball is moving eventually what we may
have is
the googles the amazons the netflix's
and whoever else is going to emerge
may buy large rights or windows and then
sell broadcast tv rights out of that
to nbc cbs abc fox so i think that's the
next
move here seven or 11 years down the
road miles
yeah it's when you have that out in the
contract it's like a player having an
out in a contract right you do it
because
you think at least a few years down the
road you're still going to be a
productive player
and so when you put that opt-out in
there you're like yeah i'm going to
maximize my
value as much as i possibly can it's
exactly the same thing here
you know i don't think anybody thinks
that in seven years
the nfl is going to go kaput and like
all of a sudden people aren't gonna
watch live sports like this is the one
thing
that people have to watch live and so
that's why
sunday night football has been the top
rated program on television for as many
years as it's been in a row because
people have to watch that live
so i think that's not going to change in
7 years 11 years whatever it is if you
want to watch these games you have to
watch them
live and see what exactly happens
especially
if there's betting involved in it and
the end result is it gives the nfl the
opportunity to create this
this sense of extreme security and
stability
while also having up its sleeve
legitimately and permissibly
the opportunity to pivot and get more
money and maximize its value at some
point down the road
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports